pensez vous qu'il puisse être candidat
anti zemmour la question aller simple
fait des réponses simples valérie benaïm
noria somptueux dîner tu dis c'est pas
marrant ce qui se passe je suis d'accord
avec toi c'est pas marrant ce qui se
passe mais tu dit également que tu veux
te présenter comme si comme tu y vas à
la piscine or moi or pour ce que vient
de dire comme si comme si tu allais à la
piscine or justement tu participes à ce
grand cirque à décrédibiliser la
politique puisque en y allant en disant
j'y vais comme je vais à la piscine tu
joues tu joues le clown tu fait le clown
et et c'est pas c'est pas dire que la
politique c'est noble c'est pas avoir du
respect pour les les gens qui vont aller
voter qu'ils vont mettre un ticket dans
l'urne et y compris en disant je serai
le candidat des quartiers ce que tu as
dit hier soir de corrélation quartier le
camp ya des quartiers à candidat c'est
un candidat des français
seraient bien valérie joueurs il faut
qu'on se parle suffisamment j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé et d'ailleurs on a
appris à se connaître tous autour de
cette table dans les coulisses de cette
émission il faut comprendre dans quelle
violence on aime moi je suis un
privilégié je dis la vérité comme la
plupart d'entre nous je fais un métier
que j'aime bas genton en page 11
je suis très bien payé je fais des
spectacles qui sont complets moi ça va
je pourrais faire comme tous mes
collègues artistique qui émane de nos
quartiers et dire c'est derrière moi moi
je suis arrivé c'est plus mon problème
moi je vois une souffrance et tous on
est des professionnels des médias mois
les médias ça me fait souffrir c'est à
dire que quand je vois à la télé il ya
malgré la berge a qui prennent la parole
comme la ce qui vient d'être fait c'est
à dire un tu te dis tu te mange une
comparaison hier six fois dans une
émission on te traite 10 lamy et toi de
ton côté tu mets un euro dans la machine
mais je n'ajoute dans la machine arrière
tu vas tout ça tu vas revenir bien on en
trouve dans le couloir ou bien tu es un
fashionista nom du parti semble étrange
non mais c'est pas le problème je te dis
moi ma bande dessinée préférée qui m'a
rendu misanthrope ça s'appelle watchmen
tout ceci est une blague nous sommes
dans une blague hélas pas les conneries
je te le dis moi j'ai été construite
nous c'est la cité non mais c'est pas là
cités mais je ne leur dis valérie si
j'ai 500 signatures je suis hyper
inquiète c'est à dire vraiment faut
remettre l'église au centre du village
moi ce que je veux c'est qu'aujourd'hui
comme eric on joue avec les mêmes armes
qu'eric zemmour il vient sur tous les
plateaux dit je suis pas candidat il
fait un débat face à un homme politique
comme mélenchon mais je suis pas
candidat alors expliquez moi en quoi la
parole d'eric zemmour va vaut plus que
celle d'un citoyen tout aussi brillant
tout aussi cultivé parce que le problème
c'est qu'il est talentueux dans ce qu'il
fait matthieu delormeau est ce que moi
j'ai mouillé a franchement et ir ça m'a
fait ça m'a fait ça m'a fait peur parce
que j'ai vu un signe quand je t'ai eue
hier parce que tu es un homme dangereux
tuer eric zemmour à l'envers c'est à
dire que par définition pour toi si on
n'est pas trop musulman on est forcément
anti musulman si on ne prend pas
position pour les musulmans c'est que
forcément on est contre c'est très
dangereuse que tu fais tu montres les
gens contre les hordes yacine moi je le
vois tous pratiquement tous les jours
parce qu'il fait sa chronique et on a
déjà eu cette discussion tous les deux
mois un signe sur voilier yacine c'est
vrai je vous dis je le redis je pense
que si moi je pensais qu'il ya s'il
était antisémite comme si eric naulleau
je pensais que c'était un facho je pense
que je travaillerai pas avec eux voilà
c'est tout donc non mais juste le fait
de venir soit juste pour aller au bout
tu sais aujourd'hui il ya un très beau
papier dans le monde qui est sorti de
louise couvelaire qui disaient ouais ou
et la parole des gens issus des
quartiers de surcroît ou et la parole
des arabes et des noirs parce que quand
on dans le débat public
derrière c'est un rouleau compresseur
je vais vous dire quelque chose depuis
hier soir moi j'ai été écarté twitter
parce que twitter est une vraie
plateforme qui plébiscitent la parole
raciste raciste homophobe un antisémite
c'est l'anarchie twitter non mais en
fait non je gagnais je vais d'ailleurs
mais c'est vrai que tu as été un peu dur
sur eric avec fashion week et je
reviendrai sur ce qu'il savait ce nom
mais un moment les amis quand moi je
monte sur un plateau dégagement de sol
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on soit quinze
artistes pour répondre qu' un moment se
disent mais attends moi je fais pas
traversé mon époque en me disant mon
projet c'est de jouer dans validé saison
3 et quand on parle de thématiques qui
me touche dont je suis issue je suis
hyper fier de venir de banlieue je suis
hyper fier d'être musulman je suis hyper
fier d'avoir des origines marocaines
mais ça m'empêche pas de respecter cette
république quand je me réveille